I suspect that many of you are here
because you came across a little book
that you finished on the flight and then
just kept on reading Jim cars is finite
and infinite games is one of those books
that gets on people's lists of books
that changed how they think about
everything and Kevin Kelley tracked
James P carts down he's retired from NYU
and it's a great privilege and honor to
have him here to speak tonight Jim cars
one of the pleasures about being here is
finally meeting Stuart which was only an
hour ago or so not only was I a fan of
the catalogue but Stuart wrote I don't
even know if he remembers this he wrote
a review of the book in question that is
one of my favorite reviews and it goes
simply like this it was I believe it was
written in the in the catalogue he said
a number of people have been
recommending this book to me I've read
it and I'm not yet sure it's not horse
exhaust and the the only the only review
I like better really is one of the New
York Times the the reviewer took ten or
twelve precious inches in the sunday
book review to say I should never have
been born you know it's it's always a
little intimidating for me as as an
academic to to be in the context be in
the presence of people in a situation
like this who actually do and make
things you know it's like it's like
truly being in the real world when I
when I think about myself that way I
realized that I I went to school I guess
I was four maybe five years old and into
kindergarten and never left I've never
really been truly gainfully employed
yeah I've just been I've been reading
books and talking to people about them
my entire life or as as people in the
Academy like to refer to it the the
leisure of the theory class I
I have one of my colleagues said to me
one day a couple years ago he said he
said cars thank God it's Wednesday I
Stewart mentioned I did retire but I
can't remember when I I I'm sure I'm
sure there's a date but nothing happened
you know I I felt like I was already
entire I retired I've always been
retired but the another thing about
being in a group like this is that it's
very different from an academic audience
because academics don't come to hear
what you know they come to hear what you
don't know and it's very competitive and
and it has a wholly different kind of
spirit and I feel considerably
challenged by the fact that you you are
undoubtedly here truly to learn
something and I hope I can respond to
that successfully what I would like to
do tonight is reflect really this is
more reflection and rumination than it
is a genuine lecture on a very
interesting and complicated issue and
that is the relationship of religion and
war it's complicated because almost
inevitably any kind of war anywhere
becomes identified with or somehow
involves the phenomenon of religion and
and we often feel that war has in fact
been or religion has been the cause of
war and yet at the same time there is
something in the nature of religion
that's really anti-war so how do we how
do we straighten out all these ideas I
have a thesis I'd like
to try on you also I've an idea that
I've never really discussed in public
before but I've been working on it for a
while as a matter of fact I I've been I
mentioned a couple of people before the
lecture I've been I've been working on a
book I call higher ignorance some
subtitled the religious case against
belief what I'd like to argue tonight
I'd like to develop an understanding and
see how you respond to it that makes a
distinction between religion and belief
to be religious and to be a believer are
really two different things now I know
it sounds odd and I it's it's a
difficult case to make and I may not
make it very well but I'm gonna try it
in a moment the thesis that I want to
discuss is simple to state very
complicated and difficult to elucidate
and defend and that is war is the
ultimate finite game religion the
ultimate infinite game now by the way in
these remarks I will use a lot of big
statements a lot of generalizations and
I'll leave the nuances out for two
reasons it's too much time and also I
want to stimulate as much thinking as I
can and in you and develop but I hope
you feel free to ask a number of
questions the or well I think it's
important to give a little kind of
conceptual background to what I'm about
to say I know a lot of you have read the
the book the games book and I I'm sorry
if I go over some material you're very
familiar with and some of you many of
you have not and this may be too brief
for you not to be absolutely recondite
but I'll give it a shot there the the
simplest possible definition of finite
and infinite games is that a finite game
is a game you play to win and an
infinite game when you play to continue
the play to keep the play going an
infinite player has the talent of seeing
when someone is about to lose and is
able when he or she does see that either
to change the rules or otherwise find a
way of getting that person back into the
play so that you you can think of a
finite game or of an infinite game
having a lot of finite characteristics
of course surrounded by people who who
may or may not be involved in the game
or who may be and find themselves losing
losing out and so on and and therefore
having the freedom of changing the rules
train changing the structure of the game
to keep everyone who play as opposed to
a finite game which which has very
definite and unchangeable rules and the
reason that rules are unchangeable is
that there's no way of knowing who's won
if the rules are changed if the Lakers
come out in the second half when they're
already 20 points behind and realize
they've got to do something dramatic to
win and they decide to come out with two
balls the they might win the game but as
a matter of fact they won't convince
anyone else they they have to play
within those boundaries definitely now
the notion of a boundary is very
important in a in a finite game and it's
very again it's very complicated there's
a lot of nuances to it boundaries can be
of several kinds you you have to know
when a game is coming to an end or how
it comes to
and you have to agree on that if it
doesn't come to an end you really
haven't played the game I'm talking
about finite games now but the the
boundaries can be of several kinds that
can be temporal boundaries they can be
spatial boundaries that can be numerical
boundaries and they can even be
psychological boundaries of course but
everyone has to understand where the
boundary is and exactly how to play and
how they are within that boundary where
they're related to the boundary now now
in an infinite player instead of that
the an infinite player instead of living
within boundaries lives within what I'd
like to call a horizon now horizon is a
very different from a boundary you can't
tell exactly where the line of a horizon
is if I asked you to draw the line
somewhere that indicates the end of your
vision it's something you cannot see
from the center of your vision you just
see where your vision ends up and if you
go to that place and indicate the line
of course now the line is somewhere else
so therefore a horizon a horizon --all
experience is one in which you you shift
you move and your vision changes new
things come into view and as a result
you are in a different place than you
were previously I remember I give you a
very simple example like when I went to
college I'd grown up in a sort of a
typical Midwestern family in my first
semester of college I took a
introductory course in sociology
it was the first time believe it or not
I ever heard the word middle-class and I
thought middle-class
it's a strange term and then what I
began to realize that I had grown up in
a middle-class family and culture
suddenly I had a very different picture
of what that culture was Who I am what
my life has been about and so on a very
simple way of moving the line of my the
end of my vision to something else
normally we would hope that anyone in an
educational process whether it's in
school or in their life indefinitely
extends their vision that they live as I
would like to call it horizon lis
horizon only now another element of
important to a finite play is it's what
I call veiling you have to when you're
when you're in a finite game you have to
take the game very seriously there are
lots of examples of this they and sports
of course as and any athletic event is a
pretty good example they while you're
playing you you've got to commit
yourself somehow to the idea of winning
you've got to be totally dedicated to it
you've got to have nothing else on your
mind yet it has to be so it's
essentially life or death but in fact of
course it's not it is the the we put
ourselves into that into that frame of
mind freely we choose to veil ourselves
now this for me is an extremely
important point because what that means
is that if we avail ourselves to enter
into a finite game it is something we're
actually doing freely and in a certain
sense also
honestly we're aware of it even if we're
not aware of where where it's some level
someplace in us we know what we're doing
what that means is that any game we play
we play freely what that means is that
even games that are very very difficult
with high stakes even warfare is
something we do freely or to put it the
other way around
it's something we can choose not to do I
remember as jean-paul Sartre and how
shocked I was in a section of his of his
book Being and Nothingness when he
talked about he made this point about
about warfare saying that even of course
now he at this point he had the the
Nazis in mind the German invasion of
France and mine even when the RV brings
the war to your village and it's an
overwhelming force you you still have
the freedom not to fight it you may pay
with your life but you cannot excuse
yourself from the freedom of choice to
do that therefore we we say or sometimes
I use this phrase whoever must play
cannot play true play is always taken up
with a spontaneous desire to do the play
when I I'm often asked naturally for
examples of infinite play and there are
many of course but one of my favorites
is when I was a kid
I was living in a as I said in a
middle-class neighborhood and at this
point in a suburb of Chicago it was
during the Second World War there was
across the street from our house and
open lot a double lot was quite quite
large for that that area never been
built on and as far as I know nobody
owned it it was just there and kids
played on it what we played on it was
this we played basically a softball game
but the way happened is that you'd get
up in the morning I lived right across
the street from this this space there
would be someone out there already
playing or you'd go out yourself maybe
and just throw the ball or I'll throw it
up in the air and catch it and
eventually someone would come out we
would play all day long and never it
sometimes keep score sometimes not it
was it was almost an endless game but
then something very peculiar began to
happen that was a summer when all this
began then school started that fall it
turned out that we all knew this but we
didn't expand secuence --is there was a
Catholic school two or three blocks away
from this lot now the Catholic kids got
out later than the rest of us the non
Catholics and they also had a different
experience in their school so when they
when they came down alongside they came
down the street where we were playing
our softball game they were full of all
this I don't know anger or frustration
or something Minoo I think if you're
Catholic you probably understand the and
and and they they immediately and
aggressively got into play into the play
of this game and and you know
essentially destroyed it but there was
one kid in the group
a little guy named John felling him I'd
have no idea what ever happened to John
who had a rare gift his gift was that he
had a way of talking to these Catholic
kids giving them poetic names speed ace
champ slugger
Tiger and and and that the kids were
charmed by these names and they they
took their place in the game with that
name with that identity and the games
went on now I have to admit though that
these these Catholics are pretty scary
people I it didn't always work for me
that the game kept kept going and it was
I I guess it was somewhere in my early
adulthood I realized that the image of
these kids coming down the street after
school had fixed itself in my mind so
deeply that I actually believed and you
know I think I still do that I can tell
a Catholic on the street I see someone
walking along there's a Catholic I'm
sure here the guy's a Catholic and it's
one of its one of my really deep
prejudices I just haven't been able to
lose it but the the important the point
I want to make is that little John
felling him who's a little squeak of a
guy who's really otherwise had nothing
to commend himself had the gift of
poetry he was able to create a
linguistic playful atmosphere that
allowed these these kids to play in our
game and allowed us to have them in the
game and naturally it changed their
lives in our lives at the same time
modestly mind you but at least it was it
was a significant change and I remember
it very well was it stands out as one of
the more interesting experiences that
kind
in my childhood I just want to make one
more point before I go into some other
reflections here and that is something I
don't stress enough in the book I think
and that is no I don't have Catholics in
mind here but there is something we have
to call genuine evil evil if I use the
terms of the game the game language
would be an infinite game that becomes
absorbed utterly in a finite game where
infinite play is ended for good it's not
always the case no matter how excellent
our poetry is that we can include the
outsider the opponent within our play it
very often is not the case that's what I
want to stress that because when I talk
about war I have a very strong anti-war
bias but on the other hand I understand
and I would emphasize the fact that very
frequently issues of genuine evil are
involved in warfare I don't want to come
back to that point a little later I want
to come back to the issue of poetry too
now I'm gonna make I just have four
categories here of discussion if I these
are four topics let me to go through
those to tell you what they are and then
I'll reflect on each one of them why
would I make the distinction between
belief and religion if if religion and
belief are distinct from one another
what then is religion and what is belief
that's the first topic second topic is
how do we look at warfare in these in
these categories what can we say briefly
about the nature of warfare that will
that maybe illuminate our discussion the
third category is how our belief and
warfare related to each other and the
fourth how our religion and warfare
related to each other assuming they're
different let me look first then at the
difference between belief and religion
when we talk about belief whether it's
religious or any other kind of belief
the first thing we're likely to wonder
is what in fact the person believes what
what someone's beliefs are a question
rarely asked is what is the nature of
belief itself of course by belief now I
mean really deep what we call true
belief the kind of beliefs you know it's
not like I believe I left my car in a
no-parking zone or I believe that
marriage is not going to work out or you
know the whole thousands of kinds of
beliefs that that in the classical
tradition er sometimes referred to
classical philosophical tradition as
opinions I mean really true believes the
kind that you you would die for or risk
your life for what what what in fact is
a belief like that what is the nature of
a belief like that other several
characteristics that I want to emphasize
one is that a belief understood that way
is the point where you're thinking ends
it's a boundary situation you come right
up to a certain point and you stop with
this kind of certainty and don't dare to
go beyond that religion has had a lot of
this in it I mean for example in
Christianity the Creed's the early
Creed's were intended to distinguish
genuine believers from non-believers the
point was if you could say the Creed
then you were a question if you could
not say it honestly you were outside you
were not a Christian therefore if you
were a Christian your thinking has to
end where the Creedence now naturally on
the other side of that there are
thinking can become very active you can
think a lot about what the meaning of
the elements of the Creed are let's say
you can argue with each other and have
have a vivid discussion about it but
still it's a bounded activity it's
something that occurs strictly within
limits so there's a limit there's in the
one of the limits is where our thinking
ends there's another kind of limit and
this is a little bit more difficult to
to discuss I'm not sure I can make it
absolutely clear it's what I would call
a temporal limit once we are totally
convinced of once we have a very strong
and clear belief we also assume that
there will be nothing happening
afterwards to change the nature of that
belief so that in effect what's happened
is that for us the true believer history
has ended we've reached the end of
significant history things will happen
but we will always understand them in
present terms this is oh yes actually
it's interesting to look at this in
light of the of this of the foundation
because in a way what a true believer
believes is not in a long now but in a
right now that stays forever
and so that the now moves with them and
nothing significant happens in history
afterwards to change the nature of that
belief this is a very big tradition in
in Western philosophy I suppose Hegel's
the best example Hegel thought there was
I'd love to talk about this but Hegel is
one of my favorites Hey but here's what
Hegel said Hegel thought there was a
contradiction within the nature of
thought itself that created the desire
in the thinker to resolve the
contradiction it was a contradiction we
couldn't stand to have him now without
well I'll give you a simple example the
in in his extraordinary book the
phenomenology of the Spirit he writes in
the in the beginning it was very
complicated difficult book to read but
one of the parts I understand is that is
the discussion of the master-servant
relationship what he points out is that
while the master is superior to the
servant the servant in fact understands
more about the master than the master
does about the servant the servant has a
certain intellectual superiority to the
master this this idea and will actually
eventually undo the master that is the
higher level of understanding will in
the end be superior will triumph that
very point was what excited Karl Marx
when he was reading Hegel he interpreted
it not in terms of the spirit but in
terms of matter in terms of property of
terms of
physical terms that as the servant will
eventually overthrow the master not
intellectually but in terms of property
and take over it own Oh take over
ownership of what the master now owns
now what's what's at stake in that is is
a contradiction the way these people are
related that requires a kind of
resolution what what fails in Hegel in
my opinion and not only my opinion is
that this process comes to an end Hegel
is the first and the greatest of what we
call end of history thinkers eventually
this contradiction will resolve itself
and the mind pure mind will no longer be
in contradiction to itself but
absolutely and identify dentists mind
well of course it's God the ultimate
infinite mind so that from Hegel's point
of view God in relation to the earth is
God externalizing himself in such a way
Minh contradictions that require God
himself to eliminate the differences
between himself and the other and for
all things to become in the end one
history ends time ends process ends in
that in that respect now of course Hegel
there were some odd things at Hegel's of
life for example he thought for a while
one of the kings of Germany that was
frederick ii was pretty close to the end
of history itself and or and the other
thing is of course that Hegel thought
that he himself his own thinking was
proof of the the culmination of history
in this in the set of ideas in other
words extremely arrogant
and and one has to say in the end
ignorant attitude what hit what one of
the consequences of Hegel's thinking is
that he really set up the boundaries
firmly there is no history outside this
everything now is intelligible we
understand everything that's why in
Marxism this is where we we know this
way of thinking the best if you don't
agree with us it's not that there's an
intellectual issue there is in fact an
existential issue you are criminal you
are in violation of the very basic
essence of what it means to be human and
you have to be eliminated end of history
thinking is extremely important in in
recent world history and it can be at
times extremely as we know vicious so
what is belief belief involves the end
of thinking the true belief in the way
in which I stated it you understand now
again I'm making these great big radical
statements it also means the end of
history in the way in which I talked
about it belief requires something else
if you think about the way people
discuss and present their beliefs you
will notice that they always have in
mind the non-believer people don't state
their beliefs unless they're stating
them to or in the interest of the
non-believer you don't state your
beliefs
if everyone already agrees with them you
you you state them really to create a
distinction between yourself and the
other one of the consequences of this is
if the believer can't believe without a
non-believer and therefore part of the
process of believing is to create an
opponent theists absolutely depend on
atheists
one of the one of the great points I
think Nietzsche made one of the reasons
Nietzsche I think is very if I had more
time I would no doubt be quoting
Nietzsche even more but when Nietzsche
talked about the death of God what he
was talking about in fact was that it
wasn't an atheist
a way of eliminating the object the
opponent to believers in such a way that
belief no longer had any meaning so the
death of God for him was the death of
true belief the importance of an
opponent it was this is something we
could reflect on a great deal I'll leave
it there I'm going to come back to the
point a little bit later one last thing
I want to say about belief is the
importance of certainty to believe true
believers usually have some kind of
textual basis for it in Marxism as a
simple example of course it was Marx's
theory himself the the declaration the
simple communist philosophy in a
religion is very often a sacred text
what's important here is not just the
existence of the text but the way the
text is used the text is referred to as
the end of our discussion it is
understood as providing truth as being
the basis for certainty the Bible for
example for true believers of this kind
answers every question it is itself the
source of all truth now this you know
sometimes it gets silly I think I mean
it's hard not to avoid examples like
this but the the the book that was being
sold in the bookstore the of the Grand
Canyon I don't know if you remember that
little little incident that that took
issue with the theory of evolution and
made the point this it was a very
popular book by the way sold a lot of
copies in the bookstore made the point
that the Grand Canyon was created by
Noah's Flood as it emptied out it
created the canyon and they felt there
was a lot of proof for this and so on
that that's a way of using a biblical
text as as a kind of template for
understanding everything else or it
doesn't have to be biblical it could be
a lot of other kinds of philosophical or
political agendas and declarations
that's believed now what about religion
if it's different from from belief I the
this is the this is the original idea at
least original for me that I wanted to
present to you and I'd love to know how
you you respond to it I was trying to
think it was not in respect to this this
talk it was before we got to this I was
trying to think of good examples of
really significant infinite play and it
struck me I've kind of surprised at how
I hadn't seen this before
that the longest most durable
identifiable traditions are the
religions Judaism has been with us as
Judaism for 2,500 years Hinduism has
been with us as Hinduism for even longer
Buddhism for 2,600 years it's on
Christianity and
Islam and I
in other words longevity is a really
significant element in the understanding
of religion know where this gets
complicated is that I'm not saying that
infinite play is religion what I'm
really saying is that religion the
religions the great religions somehow
have learned how to continue their
existence often at very great challenge
very great risk to themselves with all
kinds of Catholics pouring in from both
sides they've learned how to to keep
these traditions going and and content
is still full of life I in spite of all
these challenges so what is it in them
that will tell us something about the
nature of infinite play what we have to
remember too of course is that a lot of
religions haven't endured that as a
matter of fact scores of them have long
since disappeared Egyptian religion
sumerian mayan navajo are actually
navajo survives a little bit but only in
fragments and and so on just many many
religions around the world have long
since disappeared so what is it about
the ones that continue that can
illustrate for us or are examples for us
of genuine infinite play well for one
thing and here's here's something I
think a lot of religious people might
have trouble with these religions are
never identified with an ethnic group
with a certain belief system with a
geographical area with the political
ideology with a given culture with a
given society
they they are non identified with the
context in which they exist while at the
same time able to use elements in that
context to make themselves richer but
they are never so for example when Rome
ended the Roman religions ended when
culture a certain culture wears out the
religions that I've identified with
those wear out interesting example for
me as Mormonism the Mormons have taken
off extraordinarily rapidly the only
religion that's grown initially faster
and larger than Mormonism in my in my
knowledge of religious history is Islam
and up maybe I'll mention that a little
bit later what's curious about the
Mormons though is that they they very
carefully they seem to identify very
much with American culture there doesn't
seem to be much yet about Mormonism that
is genuinely Mormon if there aren't
Mormon philosophers or Mormon Mormon art
or music that that stands out in in in a
way that we all would recognize but at
the same time they they have a kind of
religious fervor that we have to keep an
eye on maybe this is we're watching
right in front of our eyes the growth of
the appearance of another religion I
don't know it's it's a it's an open
question for me so non identity now non
identity has a consequence to it if if a
religion is not identified with its
place its history its time its people
its culture and so on what then is it
what is its identity what I find most
compelling about this way of thinking is
that we can
say there is something about a living
religion that we cannot finally define
it continues we all try to define it
Christians are always trying to say what
Christianity is really about Jews what
the big discussion of Judaism is who is
really a Jew and and so on these
questions can't be answered as soon as
we get close to an identity we realize
that we've we missed it there's
something almost I guess the metaphor I
want here something like something
explosive there is something at the
center of these religions that creates
our thinking that compels us to ask the
question what's going on here but
without providing us any basis for the
answer it's like a little bit like from
in my thinking it's like a black hole in
Reverse it's a it's some powerful thing
that keeps sending out all this
provocation but never allowing the
people provoked to settle the issues who
is a Jew who's really a Christian what
is Christianity about what does Jesus
really teaching and so on these
questions are not answerable there is
not only the other words not only does a
religion not identify with something it
doesn't have a definable identity
religion is also in this sense the
religions I'm talking about are
profoundly horizontal that is they're
interested in vision in enlightenment in
awareness Awakening in in extended in
sort of extended knowledge
self-knowledge lucidity a new kind of
seeing seeing is very important to this
this way of thinking about religion and
seeing is always horizon all the more
you see the different you are and the
different that religion is for you
religion is in that in the same way I'm
talking about it is also a historical in
the sense which I talked about it before
history is open well it's terribly
interesting in Judaism that I mean the
Jews are probably the most exploited
rabbinical tradition I think is does it
really extremely clear on this issue you
can't solve a question as soon as you
settle an issue you have to accept the
fact that in the future someone's going
to object to it so the future is open
you can't come around from that end and
close down the system the system has an
open endedness
that you don't know how to close and you
don't know what's going to keep it going
so you can't even predict what it's
going to be like in another century or
two there is an a historic there is in a
historic a letís not the word I want I
want to I guess the word I want is
really historic ality it's genuinely
history it's really historical one of
the metaphors of historic allottee in
this sense of course would be the path
there's always a way ahead but you don't
know exactly what it what's on it a path
a way a pilgrimage a journey a wandering
you know the one of the great images of
medieval Christianity is the wandering
monk who would the so called Peregrino
who would set off in little bow dar
set off into the wilderness and just see
what happened so so that that's that's
part of the the vision of the historic
ality of the sort of unending ness of
the religion in which way and the way in
which I'm talking about it and then
finally at this point religion of this
kind also has a sacred text but the text
is looked at very differently there is a
Jesus certainly has a centrality to
centrality to Christianity we all accept
that every Christian will and
non-christian probably but then the next
question is who is Jesus and and I I'm
sure you about just remind you of the
fact I'm sure you're all aware of that
there are whole libraries of books on
the nature of Jesus the issue is wildly
open it's not closed he is a peculiar
unidentifiable unpair phrasal person you
cannot say what Jesus taught without
being challenged in some way and yet at
the same time there's a great desire and
the part of many people to say what he
taught but the desire is not is not
answerable Aristotle very famously said
knowledge begins in wonder
speaking religiously I would say it also
ends in wonder so knowledge from a
religious point of view takes us to
wonder we wonder what is going to happen
okay um I I'm sorry just a little longer
okay very quickly elements of warfare
whereas religion is is is
that is a phenomenon of longevity
warfare is a phenomenon of brevity one
of the big issues in the Iraq war now is
how to end it bring it to an end the
six-day war in Israel is is a mythic
example of a war so effective it ended
right away so so there it's a it's a
boundary way of acting and thinking it's
very important in warfare to have a
successful kind of veiling veiling is is
is complicated more fair than number one
the enemy has to be veiled we we don't
see the person over there as a person as
one of us but one of them nameless the
the soldiers in Iraq referred to the
prisoners they had an Abu Ghraib in
other places not as he and she but as it
it is it is reducing the other to
something different unknown and as it
were really irrelevant but also the
soldier has to be veiled himself the
soldier has to have ways of justifying
to himself what he's doing one of the
great tragedies of war is what happens
to people after they've done their
soldiering and this is tragic when they
realize what they've done as soldiers
but in the training of soldiers this
sort of self veiling is absolutely
essential otherwise a war couldn't be
fought instead of a well and and Wars of
course also need opponents and other
thing that that's strange about the war
in Iraq is that it's very hard to figure
out who the opponent is the original
reason for going to war is not the
reason we're there anymore and just
who's opposing us is not clear it
changes all the time
and and so therefore it's it's an
unsuccessful war kind of warfare but I
want to give a twist to that and that is
when we have a desire for war we also
have a desire or once we begin to
mythologize the warrior we also have a
desire for an enemy the enemy doesn't
create an army the army creates its
enemies once we have an army army we
begin to look for enemies I could say
more about that if if the occasion comes
up later now you see the relation here
between belief and warfare believing and
warfare are both extremely boundary
bounded activities but the main thing I
want to say is that the warrior and the
believer tend over time to take on each
other's characteristics so we have the
war foot the soldier believer and the
the nd and the soldier is Saint the
believer is soldier and the soldier is
saint we for example we monumental eyes
our soldiers in an in a in a genuinely
religious way for at least it is in the
other way of thinking about religion for
exert a Lincoln and Washington monuments
the Washington Monument is is a great
like a divine finger not only pointing
upward but a kind of warning finger it
has a powerfully religious character to
it
there's a lot of other characters you
know it's the it's the phallic
representation of the father of our
country and so on and the Lincoln
Memorial at the other end of the mall is
a temple and Lincoln is seated in it as
a god
surrounded by the sacred text of his of
his speaking warfare creates heroes
heroes are the winners of battles even
if they die as a matter of fact heroes
really have to die to be genuine heroes
to be remembered as heroes and we have
lots of ways of memorializing our heroes
we name airports after them and highways
and I noticed the other day that poor
General MacArthur just gets a tunnel
over here I can't help telling you that
that coming out on the play I was
looking for material to talk about the
warrior as believer in believers warrior
and so on I picked up the last volume of
the Left Behind series of books now I
don't want you to think there's a
professional and envy here I wrote a
fictional gospel kind of my own version
of Jesus that sold 6,000 copies and
these folks have sold 600 660 million
copies I did the arithmetic it's it's
100,000 books for every one of mine so
you know there are a lot of people out
there who are affected by then who and
and whose beliefs are represented by it
and it's really remarkable stuff I
outlined and circled and wrote
exclamation points all the way through
it I'll just share a couple of things
with you what happens of course is that
there's there's a great warfare between
the evil
simple part of the world and the and the
handful of believer is a remnant
actually of believers who take on vast
millions of extremely well-prepared
excellent disciplined soldiers the the
soldiers the the enemy the the evil
forces are called interestingly the
global community now if if this in your
mind means the United Nations it quite
possible that the head of the global
community the this the head soldier this
is a I I'm sorry I really don't mean to
make fun of it that much but it's it's
it's hilarious he dresses he dresses in
he wears a chartreuse sleeveless shirt
hung with medals and symbols every one
but the Christian symbol and and his
great huge rings on his fingers and I
don't believe the authors got him Tim
LaHaye and somebody Jenkins we're
conscious the fact that they were
describing a 10th but I'm sure that was
in them in their unconscious now the the
global community referred to in this
battle as the GC has its own television
network so when Jesus appears at the end
other of course there's all kinds of
lightning and raining of blood and so on
the the the television the television
firm of the GC leaves all this out and
what's what's the name of this
television of this television system
it's the G CNN I'm sorry but and in
other words the liberal press the
liberal media it but it it's it's such a
vivid and in a way disturbing example of
way in which in which the the religious
person has become heroic Jesus is now a
hero he appears in a white horse white
hair
surrounded by white armies of white the
leader of the of the GC is on a black
horse in his chartreuse shirt and and
Jesus comes to end everything this is it
it's the final it's it's that it's it's
the last moment history's over now I
just have a second I'll just take a
second on this the the relationship of
religion and more I go back to the idea
of poetry the poet is more powerful I
believe than the soldier Plato in the
Republic described the poet as a person
who could deceive you a person who
represents reality as something it isn't
Plato actually recommended that poets do
this to protect the integrity of the
Republic he recommended a kind of
propaganda a way of deceiving the public
but what Plato didn't quite see is that
he himself is a great poet and so the
whole thing is a work of poetry Plato
used the term poet a sore paw a sis a
places meaning poetry employee tastes
the poet but it means more than just
poetry means it means a kind of
creativity he included everything even
included cosmetics in it and carpentry
and architecture and building these are
the creators in our society these people
as as Plato sought are dangerous but
they're also the way out of the issue
Osama bin Laden in his little
Cave some were hidden somewhere was able
by means of poetry to get the United
States to spend I think what is enough
four billion dollars a month our week a
week yeah on this war all he did was
make a few videos interests a look at it
another way
Osama is less dangerous a lot of you
might object to this to the American
people than our own drunk teenagers
every three weeks enough people die on
the highways to create another 9/11 but
we are fixed by Osama's poetic deception
into thinking this is really the way our
world should be structured but the poets
can do this to something else
Osama is failing us he's a deceiver
poets can also unveil us the poet is
able to go into the temple of Lincoln
and ask did we have to fight this
terrible war didn't we rather have to
deal with an illness in the mind that
made vicious racial distinctions wasn't
that the struggle rather than trying to
keep the states together a territorial
and boundary event or Washington was in
fact the war of the Revolutionary War
necessary he's our hero
but maybe he's also our fool
Canada after all never had a war of
revolution charge the third died and the
need for it was really gone
but the poet as deceiver puts that
monument right in front of us the poet
as unveil er asks the deeper question
one of the most significant events of
the 20th century
strangely rarely discussed is the
awesome fact that the Soviet Union came
to an end without one death the Russians
got together and decided they they were
free to do it we no longer want we're no
longer this nation and it was over we
get up every day deciding to be San
Francisco or to be a church or America
or something we can also get up in the
morning and decide not to be the poet
offers that chance and the poet in this
sense is the deepest most representative
member of the religion I'm talking about
that kind of religion so can the poet
save us I wonder thank you
thank you
it's a Sun we have some questions for
you if you don't mind as we have the
energy this first one is from Sandeep
you raise your hand if you're there you
go in your experience from your research
have you come across a game where you
play to let the other players win if you
have would it still be a finite game and
if it's not is it part of the human
nature only when you know it's a it's a
tricky business because sometimes
letting someone win as a way of winning
yourself it establishes your own
superiority in the in the in the play
instead of m''d say say a little bit
differently that it's not a matter of
letting someone win it's a matter of
keeping someone in the play keeping the
issue of winning and losing in a kind of
poetic balance so it's it's a it's a
very good question very hard to give a
simple answer but but I'm always
suspicious when I see people you know
like you do with a kid who really wants
to win badly and say you you play your
cards in such a way that the kid wins
it's really kind of an arrogant thing to
do and and and isn't genuine play it's a
little bit on the trickery side but but
I understand the the the feeling and the
question sure there are times when you
really you want it you don't want to
play a game that just crushes somebody
you know when when the world heavyweight
champ comes out and
has to fight his grandmother this this
is not a this is not a legitimate finite
game here's another question from
Fabrice Florin can we find a cure for
blind faith or I would see maybe belief
in our lifetime if so what might that
you know we really really need poets
ways we do really I we need people who
can who read a great deal who think a
great deal who who are able to to get at
the ways in which people fail themselves
and not be judgmental in in a sense but
but try to try to create a larger
inclusive context and you know I I don't
know if we can do it I I was talking
with Kevin this morning I think he was a
little shocked when I told him I
actually and I'm a pessimist I don't
think we can overcome our contradictions
it doesn't mean I'm not going to try but
I have a feeling that in the end it's
the finite players that went out and and
what that means is the finite players in
the end will destroy their own
civilization civilization will destroy
itself
I think the indications are very strong
in that direction but the only way of
preventing it is not an army but I just
let me it briefly used the example of
rabbinical Judaism they had for almost
2,000 years since the destroy second
destruction destruction of the Second
Temple there was no army
there was no country that belonged to
them there was no single language even
Hebrew died and
they were they were widely dispersed but
the power of the Rabbinical imagination
kept the tradition alive
what we need are rabbis that can keep
the deeper traditions of human culture
and existence in play and at a profound
level poets so maybe I have a follow-up
to that from RJ you seem entirely
perplexed what allows you to sleep at
night and what gets you up in the
morning my wife also I love breakfast
yeah I'm perplexed isn't the this is
from Carlos Mott song isn't the identity
of religion simply the in out-group
behavior of followers versus the
definition of a kosher food or
observance of holidays I never met a Jew
I described as a follower
my my my wife is Jewish my I have three
Jewish children and seven Jewish
grandchildren they don't follow me at
all
there's no I don't think they follow
anybody I think genuinely religious
people are not followers they're
beginners they're people who start
things who get it moving and keep it
moving a person a religious person
someone who hears well don't turn that
around a little bit the the the genuine
religious teacher master guru rabbi
priest is someone who in his or her
administration or teacher
makes him or herself dispensable a true
teacher is one who disappears and leaves
it all to the student so that following
has to be understood much more as
beginning than following the Atty a true
teacher starts his student to do
something and doesn't know where it's
going
this one is from Katrina Galway who do
denna fight yourself okay yeah is the US
Constitution an example of a believers
text the endless discussion or is it
infinitely undetermined you know that's
a great question
you know you know the there's a kind of
dogma and among Supreme Court justices
that the coast like this I I don't have
an ideology I am committed strictly to
understanding things in terms of the
Constitution and it's only a matter of
law it's not a matter of morality it's
not a matter of ideology it's not a
matter of philosophical or religious
point of point of view it just it's just
law but it's interesting isn't it the
people who say that have very often a
very strong ideological event to
themselves but what's even more
interesting is that no matter how strong
their ideology is the Constitution in
the end does them in the Constitution is
greater I mean the Constitution is a
great text it's something that seems to
be interpretable easily but it in fact
in practice it's something that renews
its own originality over and over again
no matter who some Rises or how
completely their perfectly they
summarize what the Constitution means
someone has another meaning just the
take the First Amendment the
literature on the First Amendment is
enormous I mean there'd be tens of
thousands of books written on the
meaning of the First Amendment it's a
great great document the Constitution
we're very very privileged to have it it
spark of poetry by the way not law
that's poetry
so this one's from Paul King Ken Wilber
has said violence is often ended by
stronger violence in saner hands for
instance the US intervention in World
War two or Yuka Slavia do you think this
is true or is this just a
rationalization you know the it's a
great example of course that everyone
talking about warfare has to deal with
is the Second World War I I have no
question whatsoever that it was all evil
I mean that that Hitler was evil and a
lot of other people Saddam and so on
where I think the issue lies though is
not dealing with an evil enemy but
dealing or rather dealing with the evil
enemy but at the same time acknowledging
the evil and ourselves Goethe said
interesting that he'd be a German saying
this he never heard of a crime he
himself he didn't think he could commit
I think what we have to do is recognize
in ourselves the desire to do these
things or the possibility of them even
as we eliminate them the momentum to
eliminate evil and therefore I mean if
you if you address Hitler was convinced
that he was wiping the earth clean of
the most despicable evil people ever to
appear in
I mean he was really clear on what the
evil was can we be so clear about what
the evil is yes and no we have to keep
the shadow the deep shading in our in
our question go to war yes but go to war
with a deep feeling of guilt that we
have to do this this is the question
from pants
Pam Strayer they're in the back yeah why
do you think people need certainty that
is believers need certainty what is it
that makes complexity and uncertainty so
difficult to handle yeah I like that
question because I don't have another
form of my perplexity here the the you
know I I tend to get psychoanalytic and
existential on that issue and what I
mean by that is this when someone
realizes oh let me tell you a story I I
had I have a friend I had a friend he's
now dead I'm very sorry to say great
loss a very close friend who was a arrow
for me as a kid he was great athlete he
was an all-american and he was he was
amazing a beautiful he was funny smart
he he became a Navy SEAL and had a
remarkable military career nobody when
he got out of the Navy he he started a
series of businesses that didn't really
quite succeed and finally he got one
going but but the the the the business
depended on a certain manufacturing
company in Michigan as it happened the
owner of that company saw what this guy
had as a possibility
and gave the whole manufacturing process
over to his brother the owner of this
fact
and overnight that my friends business
was gone just like that and he had to
move his children and give up all it was
it was a great anguish in his life
some years after that I was on the phone
with them and it turned out that we were
we were both traveling somewhere and we
were crossing paths in Cleveland and
both our planes were there at the same
time landing there and so we made a deal
to meet in a bar in the terminal and
Cleveland some bar he knew where it was
I he knew where all the bars were so
anyway we we met in the bar he came up
to me he was a little bit late he said
you'll never believe who my just saw
that's trying to think you know there's
got to be something important he saw
that guy that gave the business to his
brother and I had this thrill really it
was it was kind of exciting thinking if
I were a Navy SEAL what would I do to
this guy so so you know I was it's a
great great moment I saw I said well
what did you do I said I bought him a
beer I said you what what and he put his
hand on my shoulder and he said hey it's
only business